number one asset in business is make the
people you're dealing with know that
they matter you don't want people on
your team who are constantly insecure
who don't want to chase their dreams and
cease working with you as a backup
career to what they actually want to do
this is a feeling it's not it's not a
series of checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
cheer for everybody over to you Mel
Robbins also if you want to hear what
Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence check out my 2:54 of
confidence series I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see when you set goals when you have an
intention on something that you want to
change about your life your brain helps
you you know I talk a lot about being
honest with yourself about what you want
and if you're somebody that's watching
this and you have no clue what you want
I'm gonna say that's total bull every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a 30-second two 5-minute video for
free every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
[Music]
I had tremendous expect success in the
speaking business I went from zero never
had been paid for a speech to literally
the most booked woman in the world in
three years flat crazy there's a number
of reasons why number one the contents
terrific I'm also a really good public
speaker there's not a lot of women on
the circuit but more importantly I
behave in a way because I know that the
number one asset and business is make
the people you're dealing with know that
they matter take care of everybody you
deal with everybody the event planners
speaking bureaus everybody has something
that they're worried about you
get rid of the worry you make them feel
like they're important everybody wants
to be around you because at the end of
the day we all want to know that we
matter so if you do business with people
that make you feel good you want to do
more business with them and so it's a
really really simple thing I called my
philosophy about human beings is just be
a fan just cheer for everybody there's
so much success to go around people have
really difficult lives they make things
really hard for themselves make their
life easy they can feel great give him a
hug smile compliment them be generous
don't be a pain in the like literally
it's that simple
when you want people to win more than
you want them to win with you that's
when you actually win sit again when you
want people to win more than you want
them to win with you that's when you
actually win I think a lot of times as
entrepreneurs we get so caught up in our
business we love our business we wanted
to win we're so mission driven we want
this company to succeed that we look at
the people on our team and we want them
to be with us forever we want them to
dedicate their souls to the business but
you got to recognize that they may not
be with you forever
as much as that might be your plan they
may not be with you forever and it's in
their best interest to actually leave
you so for me I see things in a parallel
path I see I'm running this line I'm
running down this path here and when
somebody joins my team we're running
this path together
and we may run this path together for
the rest of our lives that's the best
thing for them but at some point they
may need to jump off and go do their own
thing to me to go doing their own path
and if that's the best thing for them
then I will push them to go on actually
do that
thing because I want them to win more
than I want them to win with me and
that's how I ultimately win so a quick
example story Danny the guy who's
helping me with my becoming series you
vlogs let us stuff behind the scenes his
goal is to become a Netflix producer he
wants to make videos that he sells on
Netflix or Amazon feature-length stuff
and I pushed him so hard this past week
when we drove up from Boston I'm telling
you gotta write the script
let's I'll bring some with you on the
drive down we're figuring out what is
gonna be what I envisioned as a
brainstorming point for him what the
script could look like
I'll guilt him into doing it I found
these toys that he really likes in
Boston said I'll buy those two toys and
if you finish your script by the time we
get home you get to keep them and if you
don't finish the script I will stomp on
them in front of you you have to watch
me destroy these toys at you and then he
finished his script and it was great I
said okay you finish the script you're
early awesome what's next let's do a
casting call that's you can use my space
here TV has to do it you need a factory
let's find one of my friends who might
have a factory that can help you
basically doing everything I can like I
wake up thinking about him and his movie
and how I might be able to help him do
it thinking about location thinking
about who we can work with it's an
obsession like the worst thing you can
do was tell me your goal because then I
become obsessed with helping you
accomplish it even if it has nothing to
do with my business because I want you
to win and so his first movie it might
be on my channel awesome it'd be an
honor like to have the first video that
starts his career it may not be it may
not be a fit for what I'm doing and
ultimately it may mean that he leaves me
to go off and become a film producer
that we're working together for three
months six months two years six years
ten years or he has to then jump off and
go do this path because that's actually
better for him that's great like the
worst thing possible for everybody is
that I force him to stay where he is
that he always wanted this thing but he
feels like he has to stay on this path
where I think a lot of bosses either
trash the the dreams of the employees
that they have or don't take enough time
to support them and understand them to
help them get to where they want to go
the best thing for me to do is if Danny
wants to go off and be that guy is to
help him go off and be that guy and that
will create a hole for my business now
nobody will be in that role
for what I need ultimately I'll find
somebody who can fill that role and
Danny now loves me and it's gonna come
back right even though I don't care
about what the repercussions are like
how it comes back to me it's not why I'm
doing it just seeing him win is great
but if you keep helping people win and
even if that means they leave your
company I guarantee a good chunk of
those will come back and help you in
unexpected ways the Karma becomes super
practical and when you want people to
win more than you want them to win with
you that's when you actually win so how
do you do it let's get to some specifics
number one set up monthly meetings with
everybody in your team everybody who is
the closest people to your team meet
them once a month
get to know them build a friendship it
doesn't mean you have to be best buds
but what you want to do is create an
open environment where they feel free to
share with you what's on their mind
it'll never be a hundred percent people
always have a fear of sharing what
they're thinking with their boss even if
you're the most nicest open-door
welcoming person they still won't tell
you everything but you can create the
best environment possible - once a month
not just talking about business not just
talking about did you get this done and
here we're here's how we're doing in
this progress you might think I meet
with my team a lot I mean with them
every day we talk about all these
different things but it's all
business-related once a month meet to
talk about them talk about what they're
thinking about talk about what they're
concerned about talk about projects that
they want to work on talk about them
number two for everybody on your team
you want to figure out what the most
important goal is for them what are they
one of the life what is their most
important goal right now that might
change in six months or a year in two
years but right now what's a really
important goal for them this is what
happened with Danny right we're driving
down the Boston together I'm getting to
know him I asked him what his most
important goal is and he wants to one
day one day make this video that's his
most important goal figure out what that
video looks like for everybody on your
team and the people closest to you if
you don't have a team yet it doesn't
matter the people closest to you
your husband your wife the people who
you partner with your suppliers what is
their dream what is the most important
thing to them if you understand that
then you know how you can help me
knowing that that's Danny's dream allows
me to know how it can help him and if
you know that for everybody on your team
then you know how you can help them and
step number three is push them on it
right all the advice that I always give
to you like star
get started do something immediate
momentum let's go let's go let's go you
can be that person for the people on
your team if you know what their dream
is you've gotten to know them right
step one you've understood what the most
important goal is then step three is
push them on it figure out what the
smallest possible step is for them to
start taking action and then help them
do it hold them accountable be their
friend be their support network push
them find resources find ways to help
them out be a volunteer like I would be
in Danny's movie if he wants me to I'll
help him build his set if he wants me to
I want him to build momentum at some
point he won't need me anymore I'm
giving him the push I'll do things that
are I normally wouldn't do things that
I'm not interested in just to see him
win really badly and he feels the love
and I know that's gonna come back to me
but you can be that support system for
the people on your team and be
comfortable with them potentially
leaving your business you don't want
people on your team who are constantly
insecure who don't want to chase their
dreams and cease working with you as a
backup career to what they actually want
to do like you're not gonna get the best
work out of people like that where if
you are a stepping stone to somewhere
else that's ultimately for everybody
involved when you want the people on
your team to win more than you want them
to win with you that's when you actually
win now I've got a really special bonus
cut for you but before that I want to
know question of the day who is one
person on your team or in your area a
friend a colleague somebody who's around
you in your environment in your circle
you see on a regular basis who you are
going to be that person for who you're
gonna meet with them get to know them
better you're gonna figure out the most
important goal and you're going to push
them on it be their support system who
is that person tell me their story
quickly these aren't the name names but
tell me about that person what you're
gonna do to help them leave that in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus
let's pray so give me go
so how do you define success I think
successes is is seeing those around you
work to their natural best and creating
momentum for a vision towards a vision
that will last beyond yourself so a guy
is driving a bus for 20 years got to
retire
he's on Madison Avenue in New York
packed every day as people getting on
that bus and getting off mm-hmm
he has two kids wife lives in Queens hmm
he might call himself successful another
guy might be vice president of that
company who call self unsuccessful so
his success what you make of it so it's
so this success is defined its success
is a feeling it's not it's not a series
of checkmarks and goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines you know they well I ran a
marathon I'm successful the question is
a why did you run the marathon and what
happens after you've completed the
marathon do you just keep running
marathons what happens if you break your
leg and you can no longer run marathons
you know we said a lot of people set
financial goals I'm successful when I
make my first million okay now I have to
make my second million its
success as a feeling and and it's the
feeling of contribution so you were bus
driver in Queens if he has decided that
his job as a bus driver is to ensure
that everyone who gets on his bus feels
better about themselves because they got
on his bus and not another bus and so he
greets them with a smile he says good
morning he says good bye that people
remember that that that that ride that
they took with him versus the this vice
president of the company who's made it
about himself and his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as opposed to
seeing those around him succeed and
those around him go home with a love of
their their day you know because they
come to work in his company every day so
I still believe success and and good
leadership are about service to others
everything in your life happens for you
not to you I'm just a huge believer in
that and so my baseball dream ended I
had an injury probably gave me a
premature end to occur that would have
ended anyways in hindsight because I
played with enough great players that I
kind of know there was a gap in just
god-given ability level not work
but I think to be the greatest there has
to be some proclivity for it and work
ethic right and so I kind of maxed out
my limited abilities and so when I got
released I ended up moving back home
with my parents I couldn't find a job I
was depressed I spent about a year at my
parents house just broke in every way
financially spiritually mentally
physically and I remember my dad came
home my dad had just got sober and my
dad said to me hey I met this guy at a
meeting I got you a job you get your ass
down there tomorrow morning at 6:00 a.m.
getting out of this house getting a job
and I'm like okay I have a college
degree
you know I'm being picky for a year
watching Maury Povich reruns everyday on
TV and Jerry Springer I go down there at
6:00 a.m. I walk in I said hey my name
is Eddie might let him here for the job
they're like what job I remember this
vividly right and I'm like I don't know
they just told me you know and they go
well we have no idea who you are and we
don't know what the job is they said do
you know who's hiring you I said I don't
remember then they go well then you need
to come back and I go to the door and I
go wait a minute his name's Tim they're
like there's a lot of tins and I go well
I know he must be an alcoholic because
he was at a meeting with my dad Lester
they go oh
drunk Tim we know Tim right and where I
was was a place called McKinley home for
boys it was a group home a campus of
group homes all my boys were Ward's of
the court they were removed from their
family there because their parents were
incarcerated killed or were molesting
them and I ended up in cottage eight
cottage eight I had 12 boys they were 7
to 10 years old now walk through that
door that morning not even knowing what
the job was
and it transformed my life I mean in an
instant brother I just saw these eyes
these little boys and they just wanted
someone to love him and believe in him
and care about him and I'd have this big
belief that people that go through any
dysfunction in their family or abuse as
a kid I think our eyes are different we
just have these different eyes man and
so I could connect with these guys mine
wasn't as severe as theirs but I knew
what it was like to have that kind of
anxiety and that kind of stress and that
kind of pressure put on you as a little
boy and I became like their father I was
there with him on Christmas and
Halloween and their birthdays and I
lived with them and it changed my world
because in that instant I went from
being this athlete who was ego
recognition significance gonna get rich
it's all about me
always when you're a good athlete you
knew this growing up was always
accolades all of a sudden in that
instant it became about serving people
making a difference nothing like oh this
is what makes me happy
oh I was actually born to serve and help
people crazy no one that never happened
playing baseball and while I worked
there two years into it the financial
business that I'm in came along and I
started in a part-time and I'm the I was
the rare young businessman who
approached the business world from a
place of service and giving and not
making money and ironically the more I
serve people the more I made a
difference the more I contributed the
more I was rewarded financially I didn't
do it for that reason but that's what
happened so that's how I got into the
business was actually and again
everything that my dad wasn't an
alcoholic he's not at that meeting I
don't get that job and if he wasn't if
it wasn't how guy wouldn't it connected
with those boys so all of that in
hindsight happened for me right and and
had I met the financial business before
that I'd have flown out of it I'd have
been about ego making money and when
that didn't happen out of left and so it
all happened in the right sequence Wow
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video